every time like you're breathing out
like but with your teeth touching shut
by my lips yeah hi there I'm aria
and I've always been baffled by the idea
of an Instagram model you know the
concept of combining your looks and
harnessing the power of social media to
create a new and very lucrative
profession is a bit astounding to me
especially as someone who if you look at
my Instagram page let's just say the
word sexy may not come to mind well
that's why we're here
we're here to learn more about this
unique profession and perhaps some tips
and tricks along the way by spending the
day with an Instagram model the cars
going by I'm meeting with Abigail
Ratchford a former paralegal turned
model whose pictures began blowing up
online a few years ago and who can now
easily charge upwards of several
thousand dollars per sponsored post so I
feel like now social media is kind of
just the currency of things so as we're
maybe five years ago a company would pay
for a billboard on sunset boulevard that
gets 10 million views they're gonna pay
a girl with 10 new Fowler's to post an
ad so it's kind of just like the more
followers you have the more money you
can request what are the keys to a great
selfie good lighting for sure know your
angles and eye contact you're like look
gentlemen 1 2 very know though how many
followers do you currently have
Instagram I think it's like 8.3 million
or putting too many in image are good
god I mean to be completely blunt I
think it's you know the whole sex appeal
thing that got me here but then for me
at least I've kind of just used my
social media following as a launching
pad for bigger things and one of those
bigger things is insta give an online
campaign Abigail has launched where she
finds people in need helping them with
anything from a makeover to paying their
medical bills and today Diana a high
school senior is being given one of
those makeovers for her prom tonight
Diana here I heard you are the lucky
from and to give basically it's kind of
just my way of giving back to people
because I feel like I come from a small
town I'm the fifth of seven kids and
I've just been so lucky and so blessed
to be where I am in this amount of time
so I just was like I need some kind of
way to use my platform you use my
spotlight for good oh my god me look
amazing while Diana finishes up her
transformation
Abigail decides to assess my Instagram I
mean your stuffs kind of all over the
place like this isn't your post things
of other people other content this was
pretty interesting yeah that was I spent
the day at a porn company
Nicole Aniston are you familiar with her
work no I'm not I would give your
Instagram on a scale of one to ten like
5.8 5.8 it looks good I like it I like
it
you clearly don't find it Abigale then
takes me outside for a quick crash
course this is like called the babyface
okay the phase filter okay let's see
look down and then as soon as you look
up he snaps be like wow that's not a
good photo after giving up on my poor
selfie technique could you get one of
those flowers Abigail decides to just
get behind the camera herself hold it a
little bit closer to you like you're
smelling it and then yeah at the count
of three you're in just for your eyes up
to me one two go I love it
this is gonna go viral baby just bite
your head there's gonna be major I'm up
here if I put it nailed it
Diana's makeover is now complete -
Abigail's delight oh my you look amazing
Wow this is so stunning on you oh my
gosh I wish I looked this good at my
prom - yeah well you look amazing what
person are you bringing tonight - oh
great he's a he's a good guy yes have
you put in the right amount of money for
a background check
if he gives you any trouble I recently
took up kickboxing so honestly this
whole experience feels so like magical
like I've never thought that I would
experience something like this it just
doesn't feel real I feel like a Disney
Princess I always say Instagram is not
real life even though I try to share as
much of my true life as I can every
image that you see has been perfected
altered most girls in my position want
their photos to look the best possible
way that they can before they put them
in front of 8 million people to see so
young girls looking at girls like me
just know that love yourself embrace
your flaws know who you are and just own
it
taking Abigail's words to heart despite
feeling uncertain about it I decided to
try posting my first sincere attempt at
a serious photo later that day and as it
turns out in less than a week it's
already become my most like photo ever
while I don't know if this means I'll
eventually have as many followers as
Abigail I've definitely come out of this
with a lot more respect for what she
does she's aware of the fact that as she
says Instagram is not real life and I do
think that we have to realize that while
having followers and likes may give us a
fleeting sense of satisfaction we
ultimately shouldn't allow it to
determine our self-worth because it
doesn't although it would be nice to
maybe have as many followers as Michael
Buble someday just so we have something
to talk about
[Music]
if the guy gives you any trouble you
take him like this all right and that
that's you're gonna eat it'll knock him
out you put enough pressure he's done
[Music]